can you imagine coming back to the round
table hold and hearing this
you follow the sound to the source and
realize that it's the sound of the two
fingers slamming together
this was brought to my attention by
bonfire VN and in the comments below
that video as well folks are talking
about how many different ways this could
have been used it could have been used
to call you over to Enya if she had new
dialogue it could represent them
clapping whenever you kill a demigod or
it could just be an animation that gives
the two fingers some actual motion to be
read by the finger readers
this is one of those pieces of cut
content that's kind of baffling just in
the sense that I can't think of a good
reason why these animations weren't put
to use in game
what do you think
but just because something is unused now
doesn't mean it won't be used in the
future which brings us to the three
coliseums of Elden ring the one in Lim
grave the one in caled and the one in
Lane Del so long ago we speculated that
these might be used in a future update
as PvP Arenas and that fact now seems
all but confirmed in the recent patch
four new parameters for four new text
banners have been data mined and they
align with unused texts that read begin
match you win draw and you lose once
added presumably these coliseums will
work like the arenas from previous Souls
games that had dueling formats and
free-for-all brawl formats as well and
the placement of these Arenas across the
lands between should give players access
to Arena PVP no matter where they are or
what level they're up to in their
Journey but in this video I'd like to
mainly talk about some of the remaining
law secrets in the game so this is the
first one and it's that Arenas have
already been written into the game's
lore it was here that gladiatorial
combat would take place and it was
actually a sort of ritual combat that
was held to honor the Earth tree we
learned this from the ritual sword and
shield talismans which go on to state
that this practice had died out by the
age of King consort Radigan therefore
this combat would logically have taken
place during the age of the Earth tree
that Lord Godfrey reigned over this is
confirmed pretty much by the designs of
the talismans which themselves resembled
The Sword and shields of Godfrey's
Crucible Knights Godfrey is a character
that believed that the right to rule was
warranted by strength and fittingly
strength alone is what matters in the
arena
there are two gladiatorial enemies that
give us an idea of just how harrowing
this combat was there's the pumpkin
heads who are these mad soldiers they
are broken Gladiators without much
sanity remaining and apparently they
find some degree of Peace by having
these dark spacious helmets that calm
them in a sense then there are the
Duelists often found near grave sites
underneath their cloaks are bronze
snakes which the audience delighted in
seeing beaten and battered this is
because the snake is seen as a traitor
to the Earth tree and that helps to
explain why it was such a blasphemy when
Reichard would go on to give himself to
the Great Serpent years later the snake
already had a reputation even in the age
of Godfrey I speculate that these
Duelists were part of this ritual combat
in the sense that they were there to be
beaten down upon they were driven from
the color Coliseum as the description
States and I speculate again that the
ritual combat probably would have been
completed when they were defeated and
The Crucible Knights of the earth tree
were victorious since this was ritual
combat it would make sense for the urge
tree to be victorious over the
traitorous snake
speaking of making an example of people
a long time ago we speculated on the
crucified folk that you find dotting the
landscape in Lim grave many of these
folk are burned yet live on screaming
and suffering but something I neglected
to notice at the time was that a lot of
these people wear the guilty Hood item
which is made of course cloth with a
collar of sharpened branches that is
worn by those accused of lesser crimes
and it only just occurred to me that
keeping these so-called criminals off
the ground might have been a way of
delaying their return to the old tree's
roots again this is just speculation but
it does kind of add another layer of
punishment to their whole ordeal pretty
crazy though that even lesser crimes get
you strung up unable to die or maybe
return to the Earth tree currently
limgrave is under the reign of godric
the grafted so it's possible that he's
responsible for the punishment of these
common folk next in line as the ruler of
lim grave is Kenneth height who has some
Choice words about godric the current
Lord first he hid himself amongst the
women folk to flee the capital then hid
from radon in that castle then he
insulted Melania lost to her in battle
only to lick her boots rather than die
like a man
has seen no shame the big girls blouse
so you might be wondering how did godric
hide amongst the women folk well the
answer might actually lie in a dining
room of godric's own castle the mimics
Veil a golden veil of intricate design
with a description that even references
godric's flight from the capital when
godric was hounded from Lane Del the
Royal Capital this was one of a
multitude of treasures that he took with
him of course this item allows you to
blend in with your environment and turn
into other things thus it's very fitting
that this mimic Veil is also known as
marika's Mischief because of course
America's biggest secret is that she is
in fact also Radigan and it's a great
bit of characterization to know that
America had a bit of a reputation for
tricking others and causing mischief and
maybe turning into other things
but what if it goes further than that in
the last main law video where we talked
about the Eternal cities we talked at
length about the knocks and their silver
tears that can mimic any living thing in
that video I shared some evidence that
America might actually be from these
cities to put it briefly these cities
are named after her if you data mine
some of the names and Looking Back Now
America's mimic Veil does seem like the
kind of thing that the Knox would invent
first it's shade of gold actually
matches the cloth of their armor sets
secondly it's a veil and the knocks
commonly have veiled eyes and lastly of
course the knocks are known for a
similar sort of mimicry with their
silver tears
and speaking of things that the knocks
are known for take a look at this this
is the black moon of noxtella and it's a
Talisman that represents a moon that
supposedly hung above one of their
cities
because we now have all of the game's
icons in this stunningly high resolution
and seriously some of these icons look
so good in high resolution when you look
at the little details and because we can
look at them so closely now we can
actually see two birds above the
Talisman specifically these are cuckoo
birds and we know this because that
exact same design can actually be found
upon the crest of Raya lucaria and on
the cuckoo surcoat as well this armor
set worn by the Cocoon Knights of Raya
Lucario depicts twinned cougars peering
into a flourishing mass of glintstone
so whether the cuckoo Knights and Raya
lucaria know it or not a part of their
Crest actually originates from one of
the Eternal cities except now the birds
appearing into Glenstone instead of a
black moon there's actually so much to
discuss here and we will explore this
topic further in an upcoming lore video
on Glenstone so subscribe for that you
would have fought the Knights of the
cuckoo in eastern Leonia but you would
have also found them within Korea where
they've been turned into puppets against
their will and as we discover after
giving Rani the Finger Slayer blade
pidia was at least partially responsible
for pulling their strings
stop please stop
here my puppets I loved you with all I
have how could you forget such
I have a spreadsheet that contains all
of the dialogue in Elden ring cut and
otherwise and in it I found what I think
might be a fascinating little detail
unlike other characters that have spaces
between their dialogue in this
spreadsheet to Mark you know when a new
character's dialogue begins pitia and
celibus have no breaks in between their
dialogue and I don't know if this is
just because of the way the dialogue was
extracted but it might be just one of
many things that hint at pidia and
celibus being linked that is to say
celibus is a puppet of pydia the
albenoric mage the most telling sign of
this is that celibus dies in the same
instance that pydia is confronted by the
cuckoo Knights meaning celibus can't be
alive while pedia is dead the best test
of whether they're linked would actually
be to kill pitia and see if celibus dies
or is released from puppetry but pidia
is a protected NPC which I mean that's
pretty telling in and of itself from
software doesn't want you to kill pitia
because they don't want you to ruin
salivus's questline prematurely or at
least they don't want to code this
interaction into the game adding
immunity to pydia is much easier and to
cap off this Theory as fact note that
sullivas's death pose is actually
identical to the death pose that the
puppets have you can find these puppets
in a nearby basement and they are all
found in that same pose as if their
strings have suddenly slackened and
their lives are no longer their own
so pedia is an albinoric who uses other
beings as puppets and it's probably nice
for him to be able to control other
people because these beings are able to
walk freely and they don't face
Prejudice like albanorics do as
mentioned in a recent video albanorics
are artificial beings that are born of
silver and those without legs are the
older first generation Creations but one
thing I failed to mention in that video
was that first gen albanorics might not
actually be born without legs instead
they might be fated to lose control of
these legs over time this is something
suggested by Albus in the albanoric
village My legs will soon fade and with
them my life
my life
this is the immovable fate of all
albinorex in this Village it becomes
very clear that yes albinoric legs are
clearly fading fading as in they're
literally turning transparent first-gen
Elder norik legs fading over time might
help to support the theory that Loretta
was an albinoric because perhaps she was
able to walk normally and then
transitioned to permanently being on
Horseback once her legs began to fade so
there's a whole rumor in the game
surrounding this and it's something that
began because of the silver mirror
Shield that she wields its shape
apparently imitates that of a silver
sacred drop of dew something that
albanorics are said to be born from this
as the description goes inspired the
Absurd rumor that Loretta herself was an
albinoric but is the rumor really that
absurd let's talk about some of the
evidence she's always found on Horseback
not unlike how the albanoric Arches are
on wolfback and speaking of archery
Loretta fights with a magical great bow
with the sorcery stating that the bow
was Loretta's favored weapon again not
unlike the albenoric wolf back archers
and finally after her service as a
personal guard to carry on royalty she
would go on to search for a Haven for
albinorex where they might one day live
in peace so while it's definitely still
possible that she is just mirroring
characteristics of albinorex you can
definitely make a good argument that
Loretta might have had a very personal
interest in finding a Haven for others
of her kind
and I've talked a lot about how you know
albanorics want to find peace and
they're persecuted but it's worth noting
that albanorics clearly desire
retribution as well if you get really
close to the second generation
albanorics specifically you might just
be able to hear something
but this dialogue is so hard to hear so
let's extract it and we can finally hear
all of these lines way more clearly
stars all night or
punish them all and it's the world
entire unless
you punish every living thing
forever
always speak to those who forsake
straight
away
not as we read
the most interesting thing to learn here
I think is the confirmation that these
albanorics do indeed have allegiance to
the Stars to the night sky and to its
fate in the last law video we speculated
as such so it's great to have that
confirmation
so with all of this characterization
added to the albanorics let's finish up
by talking about how there might
actually be hope for these creatures in
the end so in at least a few forms of
media there's one thing that's often
withheld from artificial life forms and
that's the ability to procreate because
a big sense of agency comes from being
able to birth new life but at the very
end of Latina's questline that ability
to create new life through birth seems
to be exactly the gift that is given to
the albanorics
Towering sister of us let the birthing
droplet in and create life
for us for all the album oryx this
towering sister is called philia we
think and while we clearly don't know
why Lieutenant clearly believes that
she's special I gave this character more
thought thanks to you guys in the
comments of the last lore video where a
lot of you speculated that this giant
albanoric woman might actually be
related to the Giants on the Thrones in
the Eternal cities and this is because
Latina confirms that she's delivering
something called a birthing droplet to
this large woman in order for her to
create life so it's not such a stretch
to imagine that the knocks were
attempting to do something similar with
their Giants down in the Eternal cities
if nothing else it really is excellent
speculation so kudos to you guys for
that one the albinrix converge at the
liturgical town in the consecrated snow
field which is a town of worship for the
young Lord mikola who many albanorics
see as their salvation there is so much
cut content for mikola to go into and
one day I'll do a full video on it but
for now just know this Michaela already
has a voice actress and she's even
listed in the credits of the game as
noted by Zully the witch this voice
actress was the voice of cloanne in Dark
Souls 2. I never played and to visit
this God's forsaken place and Marie in
De rasane mikola has a ton of cut
dialogue lines that we can access but
never here clearly they changed their
plans for him at some point in
development hopefully they flesh out
this character in DLC and if they do
expect that voice to be the voice that
you hear another piece of cut content
that we haven't discussed yet is a cut
item in Eldon ring called Miranda's
Prayer by consuming FP you would have
been able to pull down beams of light
not unlike what the Miranda flowers can
do this description reads this statuette
depicts a flower that preys on humans
posed in prayer Miranda maiden of the
flower Crucible is said to have been the
very first of this breed and according
to one very astute Wiki commenter this
spell is actually castable by melaner if
you summon them during the fight with
morgut which is very interesting to say
the least for number 14 let's talk about
ranala again when we talk to her in game
she's pretty far gone and she's cradling
the egg that radagon gave to her clearly
she still holds some love for Radigan
who abandoned her for the golden order
she even has a statue of him up in her
room but you want to know whose statue
she doesn't have
Maracas not in the entirety of Raya
lucaria can a stake of America be found
which considering the Grievances Raya
lucaria and rinala would have had for
her this makes a lot of sense in
Ronaldo's eyes Radigan would have left
branala for America although we know
that they were always the same person
but of course anyone who has died to
Ronald knows that there's no stake of
America here the run back to ronalda is
one of the few long runs back to a boss
that you'll experience in the game so
while you're running back know that you
can kind of blame the law for that one
another little detail I can respect is
found with the statues atop every Hero's
grave there's a few of these in game and
no matter where you find these Heroes
Graves the statues are unfailingly
pointed towards the Earth tree and
that's because of all the people that
are put to rest in the lands between
those in the hero's graves are assumedly
the highest priority for bird tree
burial so with bodies held before them
these statues represent that offering
these Heroes to the great tree
before I go as a bonus secret I want to
talk about Godfrey and a character from
another piece of media that I think
might have inspired him but before that
though I do want to mention that this
bonus secret is brought to you by
audible enjoy your first month and first
free audiobook on me and visit
audible.com variety video or textivarty
video to 500 500 to claim your free
30-day audible trial so one thing I've
always found fascinating about
miyazaki's games is which pieces of
media he draws inspiration from I always
go out of my way to read or listen to
these books usually that he talks about
but there was one book in particular
that he cited as inspiration way back
before the game's release this was
called The Eternal Champion series of
books by Michael morcock and this is
basically a story about a legendary
Warrior called ericosee who is pulled
through time and space to fight in
different Wars at times of great need in
the first book this legendary Warrior is
basically wielded like he's a weapon by
the ruling powers and they use him in
order to Vanquish their enemies and I
could be wrong but out of anything else
in the book this reminded me the most of
Godfrey who is also a legendary Warrior
who is pulled out of his own age and
used as a tool by America to Vanquish
her enemies and set up her order of
course you can also listen to thousands
of other fantasy audio books just like
the Eternal Champion over at audible
because new members can try audible free
for the first 30 days during which
you'll get a credit to spend on an
audiobook of your choice again just head
over to audible.com video or text Viti
video to 500-500 where you can enjoy
your all access to thousands of or you
can listen audiobooks as well as
original entertainment and podcasts as
well included in the plus catalog so
please go and listen to something great
or recommend a great audiobook for
others in the comments I'll be listening
to some of your suggestions as well but
as always thank you for watching and
I'll see you next time